bismillah alhamdulillah Salam alaikum
that's the greeting of peace thank you
for tuning in to another episode of the
Deen show and it's always exciting to
hear people's stories how they came to
Islam which simply means simple it's
just so simple it means to acquire peace
by submitting to the owner of peace the
one God the same God of Jesus Moses
Abraham they all submitted to God they
didn't submit to themselves they didn't
submit to a man or woman but the creator
of man and woman to one God this is
Islam doing God's will not your desires
and our next guest Sheikh Abu Toba you
probably might already know about him
he's an incredible individual very very
friendly person nice person
knowledgeable [ __ ] that I just had a
chance to meet and he came down to
beyond the Deen show he used to be a
Christian spent 10 years in the Marines
I believe it was something like the
Special Forces Force Recon so he's got
an incredible story and we're privileged
enough to have him here on the D show to
share his story and his experiences with
us he's also memorized the Quran which
is the verbatim Word of God and he's
studying Islam for a long time we got so
much to talk about I don't wanna let the
cat out the bag we'll be right back with
his story here on the Dean show sit
tight
so I'll make on peace be unto you my
liquid still I want the light oh but I
can't how are you how are you thank you
for finding the time to come down to
beyond the den show I'm the last my
pleasure to come down here and see what
you Eddie we heard you got a really
great story to tell you know it's
amazing to hear these stories you you
have a lot to talk about
I just introduce some of the things I
was excited and so I didn't get to
mention you know more the things that
you know about you but that's why you're
here because we want to know about you
how you came to Islam and some of the
things you were doing before Islam and
then when you came to Islam what excited
you to go ahead and continue to study to
memorize the verbatim Word of God and to
sit with scholars and now you teach in
preaching Islam helping non-muslims and
Muslims learn the most beautiful way of
life out there the way of life for all
the messengers of God Islam that total
complete adherence submission to the one
God and we want to hear your story where
do we begin how little later villain I
mean I don't know
I accepted Islam when you know like I
said I was born and raised a Christian
and my mother's from Georgia
so she's Southern Baptist and my
father's from New York and religion
wasn't a really big deal in our home
even though my grandfather was a
preacher but education was your
grandfather was a preacher my
grandfather my mother's father yeah it
was a preacher uh-huh Christian preacher
so my mother wanted us there came a time
my father was in politics I have to
start there
and he used to be out of the city a lot
used to go up to Albany New York
and that's what at state capital was
yeah so he was out of town maybe three
times of the week and me and my brothers
we used to you know I guess drive my
mother crazy so she figured that the
solution had to be that we had to get
some religion in our lives
and so one time when my father came home
she said these boys need some religion
everybody has to have some religion so
she decided to send us to church there
was a Catholic Church around the corner
and she sent us initially over there
but we didn't like that the the idols
inside of gave us nightmares and so we
didn't we didn't like to go there my
parents didn't like the fact that it was
causing us to have problems with our
sleep even past you know wet the bed
mm-hmm so she decided to send us to a
Baptist Church that was on the other
side of Brooklyn being the boys I don't
have any sisters my mother was the only
girl in the house so we didn't
necessarily believe everything she said
we used to validate it from asking my
father so this day my father's taking us
to the church which is on the other side
of Brooklyn and if you know anything
about New York in those times in the 70s
it's very sectioned off everybody had
their own neighborhood so while we're
traveling across Brooklyn we're looking
at different people were asking them
does everybody have a religion he says
yes everybody has a religion so we do
the thing that children do we look out
the window
what about those people we see some
Chinese people and we say what was their
religion he says their religion is
kungfu so we start saying you know we
start doing that thing well I want to do
kung-fu let's be our religion there's no
no you got to go to the church got to go
to Concord that was the name of the
church then we passed through another
neighborhood and we saw Jewish people
and we were like saying hey what about
these people was there religion
nemanja we lived in a Jewish
neighborhood Jewish Italian neighborhood
but the Jews in our neighborhood didn't
look like the Jews in Crown Heights and
Jews in Crown Heights we're black and
have the curse so we were familiar with
those guys so we said what's their
religion aside they're Jews you know
their religion so we're like okay they
don't want to do that and then we saw
some Indian people and my father
my boss at all they they worship the cow
and we started moving out the window
yeah we were children we didn't mean any
harm and then we got to the top of the
hill in Crown Heights and at the top of
the hill Eastern Parkway there there's a
long light still very long light you
know thirty seven years later and this
particular day it had to be the read
okay there was a bunch of Muslims
getting on and off of a very bus you
know a real nice bus I know now that
they were going to lead but at that time
I didn't know what they were doing and
what struck my attention at this long
light was the smell they had good smell
you know you smell the incense of the
oils and I looked at them and they were
different from all the other people
because they were more than one type of
person they were black they're white or
Latino there are Arabs you know so I
said well what happened was their
religion and he said oh they're Muslims
you know and we like where's that you
know because other places he said India
China you know we didn't know this is
your father Tony
yes okay and so we say they have Muslims
you know this is yeah you know so then I
said well I'm one of them you said that
yeah I just said I'm I'm one of those no
why did you say that you know in a lot
you have the Iranian said a lot of guys
who we want without any thing I was
inspired to say you know I'm one of
those guys I'm I'm one of them
did you like how they look the diversity
or you know I like the smell the only
thing I'm out of my remember is what
drew my attention was that I smelt the
the good smell of the the incense or oil
I don't know which one it was and it
made me look at them and you know they
had dashikis in the colors and the
people but I said I'm one of those guys
and then what surprised me even more is
my father said of course you know black
were from Africa we were taking over
here in slavery so more than likely
you're you were Muslims so many people
attributed you know Islam to you know
Arabs or black people right you know it
was initially my father was less saying
well you know Africa yeah Afrocentricity
without Islam doesn't make any sense
yeah as 90% of Africa is Muslim but that
wasn't the reason why I did it
you know I I don't know
I did it but I accepted Islam at that
moment and I went to the church we kept
on going to the church but I had my
religion now okay so when I got to the
church I said I'm not I'm not going in
no yeah I have my religion
he said well you can get home you gonna
get a whuppin because your mama said you
gotta go to church and then an old man
came out another church my father was
really cool he told the Deacons an old
man came out and said I heard you scared
to go inside he wasn't even looking at
me and I said no I'm not scared of
nothing oh yeah you can just why don't
you go inside I said well I have my
religion I'm Muslim
you know and I knew about Muhammad Ali
you know I don't know about Malcolm X
that was a little bit that I knew at
that time but he talked nice to me said
you know look we need a guy like you a
little brave boy like you to go
downstairs and help the ladies during
the service the ladies make the chicken
dinner and the fish dinner and stuff
like that and they need somebody to run
back and forth to the store maybe you
can do that and I said I don't have to
go upstairs because upstairs was the
service he said no once a month maybe he
come upstairs so I went downstairs and
that's why I stayed until I was like I
was 13 years old at that time 12 or 13
years old I stayed there till I was like
17 every Sunday I would go to church I'd
help the ladies I'd run to the store
make the tables I cut the cake you know
and that was what I did at go to church
and then once on the first Sunday I
would go upstairs for the reading of the
Creed that was I had to go through that
and that's what I that was my experience
with church and still today there was
one thing they used to say that I still
hold as part of Mike Rita day and it was
to be slow to take offense and always
ready for reconciliation say that again
to be slow to take offense but always
ready for reconciliation was it
something out of the Bible they had a
every first Sunday you would read the
Christian Creed and there were a number
of things maybe about five-six things
that you would read I don't remember any
of them except for that yeah because
when I heard that I said I like that I
agree with that and then when I did
become more knowledgeable out Islam I
questioned if that was still valid to
hold and I found that Islam coincides
with that you'd be slow to take offense
but always ready for
conciliation and Allah tells us in the
Quran if they incline towards sell em if
they incline towards peace then we
incline likewise towards peace
so we're slow to take offence but always
ready for reconciliation let's take a
break and we're gonna continue with your
story remember Allah we'll be right back
here on the Dean show come and see what
everyone's talking about
but the argument here is that God out of
his love because in all honesty if you
really wanted to do something you're
gonna find the way where there's a will
there's a way
absolutely yes there are a few problems
here why were people of generations and
generations and generations being told
to worship one God ask that God for
forgiveness ask him for for salvation
seek His mercy no one else's picked up
the crime which is the lasting lasting
final revelation years eight years
inactive but the bottom line is that I'm
an ophthalmologist I'm specialist in
cataract and refractive surgery on a
medical director of the major eyes
these are not God God is the one who
created everything in his universe
that's the one I'm gonna worship and
prostrate - how can you go wrong doing
that don't believe in I'm yours
out of Islam and I'm gonna top ten
reasons why Jesus cannot be God let's
get right to it not be God number 10
number 10 back here on the Dean show
with Sheikh Abu Toba here talking about
your story you saw some Muslims and you
like how they smell so you're talking
with your father and he's telling you
okay this group he said the car there
the comfo religion this is what your
father's saying yeah well he sort of
Chinese people we were making fun of
yeah we were asking about the different
people's yeah and this is in no way
putting down I mean because we have
Chinese Muslim no love you know so this
is just your father you and your father
having is it well was me and my brother
who brought me my brothers and my father
so we were riding in a car going across
Brooklyn yeah and as we went through
each neighborhood we noticed the
different people is all based on the
concept my mother had told us that
everybody has to have religion yeah so
we questioned that as children we want
to know and so when we saw different
people we wondered what their religion
was yeah the difference that I do
remember about the Muslim group that
they weren't one people they were
mixture of people yeah so that kind of
threw me off yeah because all the other
people the Indian people were all Indian
all the Chinese people all Chinese or
the Jewish people they were all you know
Eastern your Western European and then
white people so you know we we recognize
them as that but when we saw the Muslims
we didn't know what they were even my my
older brothers like where they from yeah
you know that when we looked at them
because we couldn't see what those
people were yes but when I got back home
I felt you know I said I was I guess
that was my Shahada I got back home my
father gave me a quarter and he had a
copy of the Koran how did how did he
your father being he was a Christian
also my father wasn't a Christian at
that time yes okay he took us to the
church but it wasn't that serious for
him it was really my mother she was very
she was the most serial most serious one
about you know going to the treasure now
is because her father well
a preacher yes my father was really
mellow he didn't really care one way or
the other
yes so how did he end up having a Koran
I don't know he had a Koran in his house
you know traditionally black people have
had an affiliation or an inclination
towards you know it's LAN yes but what
usually for the Afrocentric reason and
not for the tell heed or those other
things yeah so having a quarter an is
not was not seen as a strange thing okay
so he gave me this quarter and it was a
translation I remember I read it okay
and it gave me a headache
I was a child I I couldn't remember
anything about it
I didn't know about so he you know the
prophet mohammed salah salem or anything
like that
and that was it and then on friday he
took me down to master the taqwa after
school I went to master the taqwa and
you know that was it you know I I I
remember going there sometimes whenever
I could get a chance in passed by and I
was scared
is this the masjid of imam surah al-hajj
yes yeah you know see the Imam at that
time well during that timeframe yes that
I did they were new still domestic was
still new at that time was still a
corner store thing like that
so I remember going in not knowing what
to do and a guy asked me what do you
want here I said nothing and I went back
outside yeah and then I got brave enough
and I walked in I just walked in and
walked past him and they were praying
and they were a bunch of children lined
up in the back and I just stood with the
children and did what they did so your
hold now 17 no I was still about 13 14
years old you know I was I was growing
yeah and I didn't immediately go down to
messianic aqua but within a year I we
found master d'ottawa
and so after that I'm going there after
I started offering the Salah one of the
children after soon and Salah was over
said hey let's go play ball and so that
became my Friday thing to go down to the
Masjid and play basketball and I did
that and I only prayed when I went there
I didn't know about Salah and there was
no dollar program to explain it to the
little children everybody assumed that
if you were a child you must have Muslim
parents which wasn't the case so I
didn't know anything about Salah or
tawheed or Shahada no one approached me
I said hey he takes you out or anything
like that that was my case until I
turned 17 years old so from 13 to 17 you
were still involved in the church but
you were hanging out with the Muslims
right I was in church every Sunday
yeah and on Fridays when I could on and
Saturday sometimes when I could hang out
I'll be with the Muslims playing
basketball for the most part yes you
know did you know anything about the
Christian Creed you know the father's
sudden the Holy Ghost the tree I haven't
heard about it but I didn't really know
anything about it like that no you know
I mean when you you hear things as a
Christmas different than what in a sonam
Islam
everybody is taught to study and
Christendom people just go along so yes
I had heard about it I had even read the
whole Bible from cover to cover and I
could read Hebrew okay but I didn't know
anything about or think about it it
wasn't a thought that Jesus actually was
the Son of God I didn't I didn't have
that idea and I didn't know anything
about the theology theological
understanding of Christendom yeah I just
knew that we were Christian because as
Allah says and our parents were
Christians that was the real reason I
even asked my brother
I said why why are we Christians he said
because mom was a Christian yes that we
they're just going with the flow this is
interesting you mentioned Hebrew how did
you learn Hebrew I live in a Jewish
neighborhood and I wanted to learn you
know every time from New York everybody
in New York speaks a different language
except us so I was always intrigued by
other people's languages I said look you
know every time I go to my friend's
house they don't talk in English they
talk to their parents in another
language so I wanted to learn the
language too and so my neighbors were
Jewish and I started to go and I started
to try to learn how to ride it and I
learned how to ride it you know read the
letters and stuff like that I didn't get
much further than that
but I for a period of time I could read
it you know pretty well you know but I
like I said I didn't go much further and
I want to learn since I knew I was black
coming from Africa I went to their mat
said no mess I went to the Brooklyn
Public Library Grand Army Plaza is a
humongous library and I looked up the
three languages that they had from
Africa which was Hausa fuller and
Swahili but all of them had Arabic
script so I said it doesn't
makes sense for me to try to pick one of
these three when I see all three of them
use Arabic as the the visa so to speak
to learn a language I need to learn
Arabic you know so I wanted to learn
Arabic at that time and actually learnt
Arabic before I even left the United
States now tell us you said you read the
Bible all the way through what did you
get out of the Bible when you read it
what was the message that you were
getting there was no I got I read the
Bible and it was stories I loved the
stories in the Bible
I had a children's Bible and the
children's Bible had pictures in it and
it told the story of Moses and it told
the story of Elijah and it told the
story of Jesus and Solomon they just had
different stories in there and you know
they were supported by TV you know you
would see the TV and you see that they
had the story of Moses and stuff like
that so that I know about prophecy yeah
that's what I got out of it there was
these prophets that came nothing in
there said that there wasn't gonna be
another prophet yeah so I didn't have
that mentality
it wasn't until I joined the Marine
Corps at 17 I joined the Marine Corps
that I started to learn more about Islam
and that may saying sounds strange yeah
but I joined the Marine Corps at 17
years old and the first thing I did
because my mother said as long as you
live in this house you're gonna go to
church okay now did you before we go
there did your mother does she explain
to you about Jesus dying for your sins
now Trinity she didn't cuz you said she
was really a practicing Christian well
for a practicing Christian in in this
day in time means that they go to church
you know that the the the families get
more religious as they get older my
mother was younger at that time so she
would go to church every Sunday but
there's more tradition dress up where
nice fancy hat go there and it's a
social gathering everybody knows it but
that's it you know it's like your
family's in the community you have a
standing status so to speak but we
didn't discuss it at all you know we
didn't discuss about Jesus or anything
like that did you feel like this was
something that okay because of the
grandparents the forefathers now this is
our thing this is what our culture this
is our tradition so I'm really focusing
on the Creed are not even thinking or
even if it comes up you know the people
aren't taking it seriously you know like
it's the thing the Christian dime
especially Baptists is more evangelistic
it's a feel-good you know feel good yeah
we're all good are we gonna be alright
in the hereafter yeah you know that
that's the thing that going everything's
gonna be all right and then you know a
lot of the songs that they sing come
from slavery and songs of people getting
salvation after this hardship here or
running away and that was something that
actually I liked about the church
because I used to read about Sojourner
Truth and Harriet Tubman and some of the
songs they would sing we remind you of
that struggle that they were going
through to get out of slavery but that
didn't have anything to do with religion
either had to do with our struggle as
you know displaced people's here in the
United States yeah
just kind of brought the people together
that's pretty much it yeah okay let's
take a break and we'll continue more
here with Shay a boot over here on the
Dean show
you have to pray as if everything
depends on Allah and it does but you
must work everything depends on you
that's my point you see the same and I
don't like that I don't like us sitting
here what are you waiting for
what are we waiting for right now what
are you waiting for all these people to
come to Islam what are you waiting for
what are we waiting for right now when
they're gonna come they're gonna come to
log on bring these people lost upon the
water put in our hand the ability to do
your job
back here on the Dean show we're talking
to our brother Abu Toba you went from
being a Christian and we were talking a
little bit about the environment you
grew up in and and continuing on we left
off where it becomes just part of its
kind of like habit people going to
church and then you're talking about the
old slavery songs right you know like
interesting you know in the seventies
you know we think that slavery is so far
away we don't discuss it like that but
my mother was the first person in her
family not to pick cotton yeah so not
just when slavery was over the slaves
and just disappear they had to eat yeah
so then you had sharecropping which was
done where you got a portion of the land
in order for you to keep yourself fed
but you have to work the land just like
a slave yeah so my mother she tells us
she was the first one in her family not
to pick cotton and her father was
adamant about that and she used to feel
like you know she was missing out on
something not being able to go out to
the fields and come back with her hands
blistered like her elder brothers and
sisters and they did that to get her an
education so education was a real high
priority in our family and we recognized
that slavery wasn't that far away yeah
so anyway I you know this this church
was the environment that my mother grew
up in and she wanted us to be a part of
that so we remained a part of that and
separating from that seemed as though
you were separating from your family not
in the connection that you have a belief
of Jesus or Christendom but this is our
traditional familiar thing but once I
turned 17 I joined the Marine Corps and
the first thing I did when I joined the
Marine Corps was I wrote myself down as
a Muslim and have a place in here what's
your religion and I said it's lamb so
that was the first thing I did as an
adult was declared that I was a Muslim
and I went into the Marine Corps I went
in clearly as a Muslim I wouldn't go to
church anymore I told myself now two
points we're almost out of time we're
gonna have to continue this story but
let me just get a few more points tell
me did you because we know Islam
we have life all the profits that total
and complete submission to the one God
and not to his creation it's based on
five pillars the pure monotheism that
all the messengers has got taught Coheed
worshipping the crater not his creation
establishing the prayer five times a day
paying the poor dude the zakat the
fasting during the month of Ramadan and
the Hajj if you're physically and
financially able did you know about
these no you didn't know about this but
you put down at your Muslim right okay
so you didn't take your Shahada yet well
I know not not officially because that's
obviously you know for our viewers
that's how you accept Shahada no I I had
never done that at that point you know
at that point I was I didn't know
anything about that but you you were
just what was it about Islam or what was
it just what had you just want to put on
Muslim but you didn't you didn't really
know much of the tenants of it well I
didn't know you know I took the attitude
yeah I had in christendom yeah that okay
my mother told me you know children are
pretty simple yeah my mother told you
told me everybody has to have a religion
yeah my father confirmed that everybody
has to have a religion on that road to
church he pointed out that these
different people everybody has a
religion and I wanted my own religion
also when I saw those people Allah put
it in my heart that I'm Muslim that
that's my religion yeah and then it was
confirmed by the fact that my parents
were Garvey i'ts you know great
historians of black history and
everything and when my father made me
realize that we actually came from
Africa and that we were you know
originally 90% of Africa is Muslim I
said well hey that's my religion in the
first place so I felt I was getting
something back you know I felt that I
was getting something back that I had
lost and didn't have from growing up
here in the United States and that that
was actually my true religion now I
didn't know anything about it I knew I
couldn't eat pork and that I wasn't
supposed to lie and I wasn't supposed to
take any trash from anybody that's
pretty much it but the main foundation
that I was built on that pure mine with
you that you only worship not greater
now worship in Jesus or Mohammed or just
the one guy this you didn't know and I
didn't get that you worship Jesus from
Christianity you didn't get that either
no I didn't I said the thing that I got
from Christianity would
there were prophets that were inspired
and taught and when told to come to the
people and teach them about God this is
what we believe and and that's what I
took from Christianity from the stories
that I had yeah you know and I was
actually the most religious one in my
family yeah you know I was supposed
inclined when to go to church as a child
yes you know because I like the songs
uh-huh
you know I was thinking but I didn't
participate in the service I just like
the songs you know what we're almost
we're actually out of time but we want
to continue do a continuation would you
agree to continue no problem going on
and can you tell the people like get us
excited what more what are we going to
cover in part two we got the Marines
yeah we have to go through the Marine
Corps and in Marine Corps I moved to
Japan Japan's will talk about Japan and
I learned Arabic there more okay well
and I learned about my religion in Japan
now you started to learn about Islam in
Japan Japan yes beautiful we're gonna
continue on in Charlotte okay oh yeah
thank you thank you we'll be right back
with you and we're out of time but we're
going to continue on with abou Tobi's
story on how he came to Islam so join us
here again so we can go on to part two
here on the Deen show with sheikh abu
Toba his story on how he came to Islam
we'll see you next time
bismillah alhamdulillah
Salam alaikum peace be unto you we're
going to waste no time we're gonna get
going with the second part of our
interview with sheikh abu Toba who went
from being a Christian and at a young
age his bother father helped him to pick
out Islam but he wasn't even Muslim just
a unique story he went from going to the
church to hanging out playing ball with
the Muslims too not knowing anything
about Islam to go into the Marines and
learning about us line it up in Japan if
that's exciting we got more excitement
to talk about with him Abu tober when we
come back for part two of his story sit
tight we'll be right back when outside
everything looks good you see the
hundred thousand dollar cars you see a
lot of diamonds you see a lot of females
and they think that this is you know
this is a life this is this is like no
paradise right here
with this my job to go into someone's
heart to change their heart your job is
to tell people what the truth is and the
alley of it is while we're sitting here
while I'm sitting here constantly paying
for the disease to kill was free Salaam
alaikum peace be with you
and I'm what I hope to light no better
captain part 2 part 2 are you ready you
know okay so now people can go to the
Dean show comm where they can watch part
1 if they already haven't seen it we
kind of gave an introduction how you
went from being born into a semi
Christian family your mother was
practicing your father was in New York
in and then you know seeing the
different people in two different
religions everyone had one he says
everyone's got to have a religion you as
a young boy somehow you just said I want
to be a Muslim and then you went from
hanging out at the church hanging out
playing ball with the Muslims and then
to finally joining the Marines Force
Recon ten years
sergeant nine years action hooah so now
you sign on the paper I'm a Muslim but
you don't know the tenants of Islam
where do we go from here talk to us
al hamdulillah a lot I mean well it's
like that but it's not who you are
that's I supposed to was that the army
one I don't know what the army does you
know but didn't Rico we do a little bit
more crazy yeah like that that's like a
war crime yeah you say like that Oh a
good job but stuff like that but what
happened is exactly like you said I so
you're a good ol American boy I'm a good
ol American boy so you don't want to
serve your country well you know yeah I
guess so
if I put in that regard you know what
happened I came from my family's is a
family of civil service yeah you know my
father was working for the government as
a politician and my mother as a school
principal my older brother he's an
attorney for you know working with the
government someone might just before you
go and I just wanted I don't I don't
want you to lose your plate but someone
might think now you know they see you in
a Muslim let's say the the thobe and the
hat and he's think oh man he's like he
flipped now he hates Americans or so
what do you guys say about that well I
think I fought for my right to choose my
religion you know that's what we say
democracy your choice do as you like
you know III spill blood and write mud
to have the choice as a American to
choose whatever religion I want to have
that's what the the pilgrims came over
here pilgrims came over here to make
their choice and I think it's unwise for
people to try to deny other people their
right to choose whatever they want to
yeah and I think it's pretty
hypocritical but you know people do what
they want to do the thing that I try to
tell Muslims to do is not worry about
what anybody else thinks
ya know do you focus on what's gonna
benefit you and don't look sideways does
Islam teach you to hate people that are
not Muslim like now some people think
that you know Islam you put it the sword
on the neck sakes Leptis lot accept
islam or die and we're commanded to kill
jews and christians we think this is
funny we laugh at it but many people
think this what you got to say about
that what I say pretty much is that
there has not been any historic proof
about that even just look nowadays where
the Muslims beginning up when the
Christians here in America but rather we
see the opposite you know we see people
having its Islamic phobic mentality
jumping on people who ain't even Muslim
who just look funny and they jump on him
and beat him up in the name of changing
and beaten up on Muslims so I mean if we
really look at the facts as the Muslims
who should be feared the Christians
because we see these crazy look what
happened in New York just recently a cab
drivers in the hospital after being
slashed police say by a passenger who
asked the driver if he was Muslim the
guy says are you Muslim the guy says yes
he says assalamu alaikum and he cuts his
throat that's in a cab he the non-muslim
it was a Christian he Pentagon he said
he's from a Christian group that went
over to Afghanistan to Christianize the
poor you know ignorant Afghani people so
to speak yeah you know but he comes back
and says this is a stop check or
something like that it happens twice
yeah you know so I mean but if a Muslim
were to lose his temper and strike back
then its terrorism yeah you know I think
that it's nonsense and they did the same
thing to the Japanese and locked them up
all in these concentration caps they had
the same thing about Jews no Jews no
dogs no [ __ ] you know they do the
same same thing with the blacks don't
drink at the same water fountain and
don't use the same urinal and now
they're doing it with the Muslims is
this constant mentality but you know our
is to recognize that we don't have
anything to prove to them our thing is
to prove what we can't prove to Allah
that's what our focus should be and not
look sideways this is a lot of someone
says someone might think this is a moon
god or something lalla hamdulillah
there's different languages if you say
ideal so you say you know different
languages that they say God the object
of worship Allah is an Arabic word that
means the one and only God this the same
God of Jesus Moses same God Jesus Moses
Abraham you know all these none of those
prophets came and said anybody different
got you they just mentioned God then and
the expression of the the theological
expression which we call Sharia or
legislation of law which guides your way
of life because our religion our
religion is not Islam our religion is
the religion of Abraham yeah you know we
all go back and say we found out the
religion of Abraham but our way of life
how we practice our day to day life that
is the Deen the way of Islam yeah so we
practiced the religion of Abraham and
our way of life is that of Islam Islamic
way of life just one more point I know
we're going off you know on a tangent
here we're going to come back to the
Marines but tell us someone says because
you know a lot of times people won't
listen there's there's a mental block
until you remove some of these
misconceptions someone might say no
those are the Muslims that killed us
like you had this Bill O'Reilly on the
view
Roslin's didn't kill us and he said
those are the Muslims that killed us on
9/11 how would you respond you're a man
and knowledge people that come to you to
learn about Islam what would you say
Muslims killed us on 9/11 is this the
truth no it's not it's never been proven
number one it's never been proven first
of all let me say this my cousin I'm a
New Yorker so our family my cousin was
there my cousin Camilla was there and
when that 9/11 she had to jump off on a
barge and get out of the city I was
there when I heard I wasn't Brooklyn I
went downtown and I helped out in
everything that was going on you helped
that's right I was down there with not
me you were helping you know clearing
debris pulling people out I was there
the day it happened okay I was in New
York City I'd come in from out of the
country
with my daughter Rambla she had malaria
and so I came to went there to help you
didn't go like burning a flag or
something so yeah so rooting and stuff
no no no I just heard of Muslims deines
yes Muslims died also you know and so I
went downtown and I did my part as a
human being to help out in the situation
at hand and I was just as as scared and
I was just as emotionally full as
everybody else there and that's just a
human factor were all humans at the end
of the day however this thing about
Osama bin Laden and George Bush and all
this other stuff this seems to be a
problem they have and the rich people do
anything and then we everybody else has
to quote unquote suffer from behind it
most of the guys that they told us did
it were even from Egypt or Saudi Arabia
the two places that they are allies with
America we're not in Saudi Arabia or
Egypt fighting we were fighting over now
in Afghanistan and this type of thing
like that I think that the people in New
York as a New Yorker people in New York
don't blame the Muslims I was there we
saw whatever we saw the plane it wasn't
no you know civilian plane I mean
everybody can go and do their own
research and find out what actually
happened the main thing I want to know
whoever did it this is a criminal act
but tell us does Islam rather be Muslim
whoever does Islamic
anything to do with this no Islam
doesn't have anything to do with that
there's that period that's a period
point-blank
so Islam is free of this kind of Islam
is free of that okay and we don't have
any other examples of where they say
that Muslims are doing this type of
thing that has been proven Muslims I've
ever done this think yeah in fact what
we have from history anybody does their
due diligence they will find that the
societies have been the safest when the
Muslims came in those societies have
been the safest say this is where the
historian historically and and and I beg
to differ
a big with anybody to come and bring
something that differs from that any
dissenting opinion with that whenever
the Muslims were in charge Christians
were allowed to freely practice their
religion Jews were allowed to freely
practice their religion it wasn't until
when other people took over that this
thing's changed look at the Spanish
Inquisition
this was the Inquisition after they ran
the Muslims out in order to change and
make sure monotheism did not last even
in the Christians that remains in Spain
but you don't find a Spanish Inquisition
when the Muslims rule when the mores of
the muslims ruled Spain for over 800
years there was Christians there
practicing their religion there were
Jews there practicing their religion
they don't leave and run away until the
Spanish Christian Inquisition comes when
they start killing the people when the
people were having and the Crusaders
came and started burning crosses on
people's heads when they had headaches
you know when the Muslims landed into
Sicily and built the first gardens and
the people said we can't eat this garden
what do you do and the muscle said you
look at it it's pretty you know it's
still today they're one of the most
beautiful places in in Sicily all the
gardens that they have there so the
Muslims didn't bring anything but
culture and civilization this is you
know these are amazing facts not
fictional verified I mean we we talk
about the European Renaissance remember
the Renaissance historically comes at
the advent of the Muslims entering
Europe prior to that they're wearing
wolf skins and they die themselves blue
trying to clean themselves they're not
washing when the natives have their
menstrual cycle out of fear they're
going to die and the Muslims come and
build all these places of Education
matter of fact there's a little known
fact that Muslims are the original
people who started hospitals that's in a
Muslim invention and they brought it to
these places and now and most of
major churches that you find in southern
Europe are used to be mas used to be
masjids that they converted into now
some synagogues or big cathedrals in
fact the larger Cathedral in Spain is
the must keep that which was the mass
the Great Mosque in the time of the
Muslim empire we're gonna take a break
and we're gonna come back with more your
story this is some great information I'm
sure we're moving all the misconceptions
out of way so the truth can penetrates
and the truth could be made clear and
the Dean should be right back we have a
question from a Christian who says I was
born a Christian I was raised a
Christian wants to take a look at it
challenges the reader who if you find
one contradiction it can't be from God
but the rational idea the rational
explanation is you do your best to obey
your Lord you will fall short nobody's
perfect all of us make mistakes you do
your best and then expect from God's
mercy what's the purpose of my life why
am I here is it just a play have fun go
to the nightclubs kick it on the
weekends earn some money have a good
time and then I die she's really not
looking to get into a relationship just
to kind of you know wham bam thank you
ma'am and and walk away from it the way
that men are why do I have to convert to
Islam if God made me a Christian if God
made my family a Christian then why
should I change that way because God is
the one who created me in that way and
most obvious when they pray they pray in
this way they say Oh God if you are
there many messengers who start with
Adam Abraham Moses David soon Iman and
Jesus and we say peace and blessings be
upon all of them I made a promise to my
trader on that day I promised that if he
would save the life of my child
and alone running this universe that he
doesn't become bored he doesn't die he
doesn't eat and go to the bathroom he's
not a man that has an area code a zip
code now you consider
fingerprint him take his picture and the
girl say oh he's cute a lot of you out
there know exactly what I'm talking
about
well handling
back here on the Dean show time is short
we just you know we went off a little
bit tangent but you know you sit with a
lot of people a lot of people are
ignorant some people really are sincere
but and you got to move the junk out of
the trunk before they can see the real
deal and Islam is not a new religion
brought by Mohammed we say Islam is
venison since time immemorial and all
the prophets of God they practice Islam
their complete submission adherence to
God's law Sharia right law they all
practice Islam Jesus peace be upon him
Moses and Abraham all of them this is
what we're talking about and this is
your story today here on the Deen show
Islam has nothing we just before we left
to do with 9/11 Islam condemns the
killing of innocent men women and showed
this is a fact now fiction this is fact
not fiction so now and you and you gave
some beautiful examples that people can
go and check the histories ourselves
yeah so but this is we not our topic
today but we want to know now and time
is short you went to the Marines and now
you started become a good Muslim what
happened no it's not how it happened I
joined the Marine Corps alhamdulillah in
1985 yeah and once I joined the Marine
Corps I had the good fortune of being
put in a team called the second force
recon and second force recon company
it's like the smallest unit in the
Marine Corps Special Forces select the
ninjas it is just like the ninjas we
some people mistake us for the Navy
SEALs but with a marine side of the
house you know we said we're better than
them we always have a real high
competition with those guys because we
work together so I'm in this unit and
we're doing extremis hostage rescue
we're doing a taking over platforms and
I didn't want to fight against the
Muslims at that time we were going
towards the Gulf so I said let me change
my orders and go towards Japan yeah and
again I'm not offering salat I'm not
offering Salah because I don't know
you're not doing the second pillar of us
on the prayer I'm not doing anything I'm
just saying I'm just not eating pork
yeah that's pretty much it are you
praying to God no but I mean I'm praying
making duaa but I'm not
- I'm praying to Allah - Allah - Allah
my grandfather used to always pray to
Allah yeah okay but he never offered
Salah so I knew to pray into the in the
name of Allah and not to pray in the
name of Jesus grandfather's your
father's father my father's fault okay
right but he told us he would never join
us now because he was he didn't like the
Arabs yeah and he would enjoin
Christianity cuz he didn't like the
whites that was your father but he knew
that my grandfather so but he said he
knew that Allah existed and that law was
the reality okay so I used to pray to
Allah behind that understanding but I
had never gone to the message it because
I didn't think there was a message on
the base when do you pray to God when
times got tough or when whatever I
remembered you know you know it wasn't a
schedule thing it was just something
that whenever it crossed my mind
whenever some dangerous happened I would
make dua and ask Allah to make me get
through this type of situation so yeah
go ahead so then what happened one day
you know I don't have much friends
because you know in Force Recon they
think you're crazy
so you know he's jumping out of
airplanes you're scuba diving you know
you've sniper school how many people
want to get close to you know people
don't like the snipers so one time this
guy he comes next to me while I'm eating
my lunch and he says to me can I sit
down I say sure he sits down with me and
he says hey uh I was at the chapel and I
just accepted Islam and your name is on
a list they're saying that you're the
senior Muslim here on base I didn't know
ever to go to the chapel because I
didn't know that there would be anything
there for me but I do remember that I
signed up that I was a Muslim so they
had that on record at the chaplain and
so he came to me says look I need to
learn how to pray he's talking about
Salah I didn't know what he was talking
about I said you know it says here on
his paper they gave me at the chaplain
that you know he's supposed to pray five
times a day but I want a Muslim to show
me how to do it so I said okay let me
see the paper he shows me the paper and
I really realized that I don't know what
he's talking about here so I lied I said
look I gotta check this out because they
might have gave you the wrong thing you
know I'm Jeff in it to try to get around
the fact that I don't know this thing
and I want to get more time to look at
then he says oh sure you know you can
have it and you explain it to me then we
were walking out after we finished
eating and I remembered that the next
day I was going for Japan I was leaving
for Japan so I say to him look I'm going
to Japan I'm not
be able to do this can I keep this paper
so I can check it out he says sure I can
get another one from the Chaplin and I
never saw that man again
and I feel that he was an angel Allah
knows best and maybe pushing it but I
feel that this man was an angel the law
sent to me to teach me about Salah
because the flight to Japan from the
America is like 20-something hours so
very long flight and I'm reading this
whole pamphlet while I'm there and I
finished it while I was on the flight
and I dropped it on the floor and I said
so found a lot it's like some kind of
law but in mind I said wow you know I
wonder what it's going to be like to
pray five times a day
okay accepted that reality and when I
got to Japan the first thing I did after
I unpacked my bags is I prayed solo and
I followed the little paper on the
swords giving you like the the shaman's
and when you say in transliteration and
I prayed in the first salon I believe it
was Oscar Salah again and because it was
in the afternoon and I prayed it and I
kept on following the paper within a
couple of days I knew how to pray how
long did this struggle because many
people they accept Islam or some people
in your situation they are Muslim but
they don't know the tenants are just you
know getting by but now what was it that
really had you cross over because you
memorized the whole verbatim Word of God
the Quran and you you you went overseas
to study you know to learn the religion
to sit with scholars what really pushed
you through to take these what rips what
what happened to me was I realized that
that whole period of time that I had
wasted was because I hadn't gone to the
Masjid
okay I hadn't been a tied to the Masjid
so what I did after that I went to the
Masjid in Japan and it was a lot of
Muslims in the message there at that
time because at that time a lot of
people weren't coming to the United
States from Africa or and and whatnot so
they went to Japan to go get their
education or they went to Russia and so
there were a lot of Muslims in Japan and
I learned how to speak Arabic in Japan I
learned how to pray I learned I
memorized the 40 hadith and when I came
back
one it was the 90s and I wanted to know
if I could fight jihad you know I wanted
to go fight jihad cuz I've been in the
Marine Corps all this time I wanted to
do the same thing for the Muslims but I
couldn't tell what was a real jihad and
what wasn't a real jihad so I said look
I don't want to get tricked up and put
into a situation that's not real how
will I know and so my friends the people
at the mosque said you have to study
when you study then you'll know what the
reality is and what's not the reality
and no one were able to trick you so
instead of going in fighting jihad I
went overseas to study to learn my
religion and know the difference between
right and wrong and that took me ten
years now this is a good point because
some people would you say they get
tricked you hear like the Christmas
bomber someone putting a bomb in his
underwear or the Times Square bomber you
heard of this man right do you feel like
these were people that were tricked and
they if they would have sat with people
of knowledge and and that's why it's
important to be around people of
knowledge they wouldn't have got tricked
and it wouldn't be right now locked up
you know wait their whole life is gone
now what would he ever say about this I
say that there's a famous statement that
the wolf gets the Sheep that's the
furthest from the flock so if you and
yeah the LA Milan Jamaat the hand of a
laws with the Jamaat with the group so
stick to the Masjid if you go to the
master and stick to what it's Orthodox
the Sunna of Islam practical it's not
you won't get in these things but they
always get the people who are not really
knowledgeable about what Islam is about
are these type of people who might have
emotional problems and so they tricked
them into doing their bidding this just
the work they do this with Christians
they do this with Muslims it's just that
the media plays on the Muslims more
because that's that the in thing
nowadays but this is not Islam these are
individuals who got tricked into doing
some foolish things you know and they
they probably didn't know anything about
the religion you don't find scholars
doing this thing you don't find people
that are praying five times a day doing
these things what you usually find is
the guidance off to the side who's
emotionally attached to something or has
some type of a mental problem getting
mixed up in these types of affairs so
that's what I did I went and I learned
more about my religion and I stuck to
what was orthodox in Islam
then I was able to come to the point
when I came back to United States then I
was beneficial to those around me to
teach them what is true Islam and what
is not and now I try to do that for my
people not try not to let them get
tricked off and by all these other
things and these people that come up
with these strange ideas and say no we
are responsible as Muslims here's
convert or revert Muslims to say hey
this is the reality of our religion not
what these other people are saying and
we have an obligation to save our
younger brothers or the ones who are
newer to Islam to express to them and
those also the face of Islam has changed
we have a lot of Muslims were born
Muslim now than our American and they're
in the same situation as the revert
muscle and so that makes it even more
imperative for us to make it appeasable
and make it clear to them to the Muslims
what Islam really is yes you know Islam
SUEZ long we're gonna take a break and
we'll be right back with more Jana Dean
show it's love prohibits killing of
innocent human beings human life is
precious and we're gonna bring you
another self-defense okay you see he's
grabbing me by my collar
okay and now from here I've tried to
defuse the situation it's not working
now I know defusing the situation ami
foot his hands I got to defend myself
okay so how am I gonna do it and suffer
the least amount of damage because again
I try to defuse it's now working okay so
from here I'm gonna grab the wrist all
right this is a bent arm escape if the
arm is stiff
so it's a I grab the wrist okay
one god wish come along do what he wants
you to do put your desires this thing
inside you that just wants this and
wants that and you just can't get enough
you know what you never get enough until
the dirts in your mouth don't let it
come to that be sincere and honest ask
the one who created you to guide reach
the first step put off chasing all the
women and the good times and the parties
and this and that there is no one worthy
of voice ship except a lot don't wait
you never know if this would come today
for you
back here on the Dean show and we're
talking to sheikh abu Toba and you said
something key you know you you were
gonna oh you're like I want to do jihad
Woodyard simply means to struggle and
strive is that what really you know
there's two meanings the jihad yeah you
know when you initially hear jihad you
think about fighting and going to war I
was a warrior I joined the Marine Corps
was seventeen years old so that's what I
knew so when I heard of jihad I'm
thinking of like what the Christians
think of the Crusades yeah okay and that
was very you know picturesque for me I
had a romanticized idea about that so
that's what I wanted to do when I came
back and hamdulillah that I was sticking
to people of knowledge they told me hold
on now
that's not the thing to do you know
knowledge precedes words in deeds so you
have to seek knowledge before you do or
speak about something you don't know
what jihad is jihad is first and
foremost the struggle that a person goes
within himself to establish Islam in his
life you know and I used to hear that
and say ah get out of here you know
you're soften it up you're being a
polemic but no but that's what the true
jihad is to struggle within yourself to
purify your soul and to fight your
negative ego who tells you you're bigger
than what you actually are and then
there is a physical jihad where the
Muslims defend the lands of the Muslims
or they may do something else and
fighting against non Islamic ideas but
this is done behind the a government you
know how and we don't have that not
these days we don't have so that is not
gonna be as you hat like that unless
someone attacks the Muslims and then
what you had is considered someone who
tries to rob you then you're in Jihad
protecting yourself yeah you have a
right now someone comes in your home no
matter it's a god-given right to defend
yourself and this is even an American
law yeah you know you fight a guy that's
in your house that's you have a legal
right to do that this is a type of jihad
also you know so this is the type of
thing that people are finding in other
countries when you're attacked and they
fight and they say they're having it you
had and they think that okay these
people are wrong no it's okay to defend
yourself but that's not what I had in
mind yeah so I was squared away
I was told you go seek knowledge first
about the what true jihad is and that
was the struggle within yourself you
can't even control yourself how you
gonna control anybody else yeah and so I
started working on that and I'm still in
the battle every day yeah to try to make
this internal jihad and straighten out
my life and be an example for my
children and to help my students and be
a good person and to put this a force as
this is what our people need more than
they need to go out and fight some party
someplace else even though it's so
crucial and important that not only do
the not yet Muslims the non-muslim that
they hear this and they clear this
misconceptions that we we just some
renegades and we're just trying to you
know kill people and all that but also
for the for the for the Muslims who have
the name tag Muslim but they don't have
the proper knowledge and this renegade
mentality and that's where you got like
the Times Square bombing and the
Christmas Day but they need proper
knowledge and this is good that we
addressed this so inshallah someone who
might have some crazy ideas this might
even stop him or her whoever the advice
I give to the the Muslim who wants to
get involved in Jihad quote unquote
stick to the message the first thing if
you want to be a good Muslim you have to
be a good Muslim and what does that mean
pray five times a day
that's jihad paying zakat save your
money and pay zakat or poor do save your
money and go make Hajj fast every day of
Ramadan with not just the food but from
the mentality that you're supposed to
have when you're fasting and understand
what it means to say Leila hail Allah
Muhammad are someone that is jihad okay
that's that you had that you need to
fight first and foremost and then that
other thing you need to leave that alone
because this is not the time for that
you know and that's what people need to
realize as far as the the the Christian
or the non-muslim what they think about
that I'm not so concerned with that as I
am concerned with the Muslim
understanding what his obligation is to
himself and to his Lord you know and
this other thing is just doesn't make
good sense for them to get themselves
involved in things that they're not
ready for okay and this doesn't have a
true standing in today's society we're
gonna have to I mean we just just
crashed upon a surface surface with your
story we went off he
in there and you got some more
interesting things to share with us
we're just gonna have to continue on how
do you feel I'm okay you're all good yes
sir
okay so insha'Allah we're gonna continue
on to talk to you a little bit more
about you know how you came to Islam and
where you're at today on the next
episode
inshallah God willing and sure Thank You
Monica hey Lake was Salama to it but may
god almighty allah reward you in
abundance I mean thank you thank you too
and that's all the time we have for this
week's show you got to learn a lot here
for our brothers in humanity who we want
to be our brothers in fade you see that
Islam has nothing to do with such events
is 9/11 Christmas bomber New York Times
Square bomber Islam is not trying to
throw bombs this stomach is trying to
have you establish peace with the one
who created you the owner peace the one
got and that's how you can truly have
peace with yourself
and you can have peace with those around
you and you as you heard the shakes a
focus on yourself do that jihad that
struggle and striving to be the best
human being that you can be focus on
that and we're gonna have to continue on
talking with our brother to learn more
of how he established Islam the way of
life of all the messengers over God how
he firmly established it in his life so
we're gonna have to do another show with
Sheikh Abu Toba be looking out for that
you can go to daddy show com2 see part
one and in sha allah there'll be another
talk with him because we got more to
discuss until next time peace be unto
you a lot of you out there are in the
exact same position they say I would
never give up for spring got his way I
wouldn't never give up spreading this
message
take that necessary step you don't know
if you're gonna live till tomorrow so
you got to find that urges to do the
right thing right now
just one firefighter everything for
maturity people you talk to yeah they
know they got to change they know they
got to do good but they don't do the
good why is this [ __ ] the ranking of the
100 most influential men in history the
world lazyness the reality of life
usually doesn't sink in until tragedy
comes you know this is when you find
people yeah yeah okay tell me about it
yeah
you get a few bad people the media grabs
a hold of that and spends it the way
they want to and in it he puts Muhammad
as number one he said no human being had
more influence one of the amazing things
about Islam that everyone should know is
that we are the only other religion that
is a tenet of faith that you must
believe in Jesus Christ and everything
that he did or you cannot be understated
if that is missing if you say that you
do not believe in Jesus you have stepped
outside of his none you can not be a
Muslim is that ended our faith to to
believe in and love Jesus Christ
these are not God God is the one who
created everything in his universe
that's the one I'm gonna worship and
prostrate to how can you go wrong doing
that don't believe it I'm yours out of
this long and I'm gonna top 10 reasons
why Jesus cannot be God let's get right
to it not be God number 10
either a long long long love what handle
in laughs you'll be glad you did
you